latest now from the double murder trial
of attorney Alex Murdoch yesterday
jurors heard emotional testimony
alleging that Murdoch stole from his law
firm's clients and also stole from his
own friends prosecutors claimed the
alleged Financial crimes were a motive
in the eventual murders and Murdoch he's
pleaded not guilty to killing his wife
and his son back in June of 2021. Nikki
Batiste is covering the trial in South
Carolina where one of Murdoch's closest
friends took the stand just yesterday
shocked betrayed mad I mean I don't know
numb Alex Murdoch's best friend Chris
Wilson did not mince words on the stand
Thursday he said he felt betrayed when
he discovered Murdoch stole nearly two
hundred thousand dollars from him that's
in addition to the more than five
million dollars Murdoch is accused of
stealing from his Law Firm Wilson
testified that he confronted his friend
he didn't say anything broke down crying
and said you know
I'm sorry
I I've had a drug problem I'm addicted
to opioids something like 20 years
Wilson said Murdoch admitted to taking
his money he said you up I'm sorry I
you up
a lot of people up he also told jurors
Murdoch said he'd been hiding a drug
problem for years when we would
socialize together didn't see
anything that indicated
that he was addicted or had a drug
problem a few hours after that
face-to-face meeting which was nearly
three months after the murders Murdoch
told police he was shot in the head on
the side of the road later he admitted
the incident was a botched suicide
attempt to get 10 million dollars in
life insurance money for his surviving
son Buster the son of the Murdoch's
housekeeper also testified Murdoch stole
from him and his brother if I remember
correctly I'm gonna kind of take care of
you boys Tony satterfield's mother died
after she fell at Murdoch's home in
2018. Murdoch told her sons to sue him
they did but Satterfield says Murdoch
stole the more than four million dollar
settlement and did he ever pay you one
dime no
Murdoch has since apologized to the
Satterfield family and agreed to pay
back the 4.3 million dollars they're
owed today testimony regarding Murdoch's
alleged financial fraud should wrap up
the trial is expected to last about two
more weeks before the jury begins
deliberations David
cupitis still on the case thank you
Nikki